gentlemen this sort of struck me this
morning I want to have a quick little
chinwag which you guys are banished I
use that term you only get so every time
only one mics on I had a comment about
it at some point and it never fails yeah
it's the visual inside my head it just
gave it life it's another reason why the
podcast version is slightly lacking and
thank you so much by the way to everyone
who's been subscribing and reviewing us
we really appreciated our Jess as I was
saying uh I was thinking I was watching
the one of the latest episodes of the
jêng position Jim starting was talking
about how plants vs zombies garden
warfare 2 is oddly unique in that it
doesn't have a season pass right which
is unique considering its a game put out
by yay right and then also sort of
thinking in a far cry primal which is an
ubisoft game and they tend to also have
done season pass or launch DLC or
something that's also a game that has
launched with none of that and then we
think it was like earlier this week or
late last week one of the developers on
the division for Ubisoft was getting out
there saying there won't be any micro
transactions on launch and you know
there won't be any pay-to-win stuff at
all in any stage and people are sort of
getting at ahead of this in a way that
they weren't last year when like we had
the evolved problem where this was a
game that was coming out which had 12
different well did not talk to me only
had like three or four different ways to
buy it which if you actually put the
time in wasn't that complicated but it
totally scrambled people because they
felt like oh god I'm gonna buy a
sixty-dollar game and then suddenly I'm
not gonna have like the best version I'm
gonna have this like right truncated
version yeah so do you think like I know
it's like it's only two pieces of data
it doesn't represent like an overall
trend redditing but do you think that
maybe games companies now are being a
little bit more hesitant when it comes
to being so upfront about their season
passes I think they're willing to
experiment now I think they're finding
that there's a certain amount of the
audience that doesn't really like that
idea and doesn't latch on to it the
other side of that though is the fact
that you look at something like pvz2 and
Far Cry primal there's sort of built on
the back of existing games mmm and they
might not need that extra financial bump
that comes from a season pass and so
it's a good opportunity to experiment
with
offering it that might help them
incentivize it the division on the other
hand that's very different yeah because
that's a whole new property that seems
to be pretty complicated and taking a
long time to make so the fact that
they're not trying to get more money
back through season passes an extra TLC
and microtransactions does seem a bit
odd to me it almost seems
counterintuitive that you're right like
when it comes to they tend not to do it
for these these are two franchises which
I've been like relatively established
and people know what they are but then
you would also think that if you want to
sell DLC you'd only do them in a
franchising which is like a fan base rec
Assassin's Creed is a good example of
like oh I love Assassin's Creed I'm
gonna buy the game and I get the season
pass because I'll be all in like for
instance for ladders one for me we're
like I haven't bought the season pass
actually I've just I wish I had never
because it's just gone up by 20 bucks
this morning right damn it yeah and [ __ ]
yeah but uh yeah like that those are
situations in which yeah of course i'll
buy cuz i'm like i'm a fan of this
series i have never purchased two
seasons i dunno no never I to me the
idea of throwing down money for things
that you are totally blind to like they
might say oh we have X number of
expansions and and this type of you know
additions like characters or stages
coming or whatever but you really don't
know what you're getting into I mean if
all that one's a perfect example because
they put the price up because they're
like oh it's actually gonna be more yeah
but it still shows that they didn't when
they were putting a price talk I did oh
yeah they had no clue yeah it seems like
such a shady business move to me I don't
think it's evil but I just think it
confuses everybody in terms of like how
we think about these games like is it at
what it is at launcher is it what it is
six months after all yeah so I don't
know because it's never really clear to
me like what I'm getting if i invest in
that I just don't it's weird i wonder if
it if it's so particular game to game as
well because there are some games where
it's like you I can't like fallout I'm
like oh yes I guess season pass stuff
makes sense because it's this large open
world and you can plug stories into it
whereas when I think about a game for
whatever reason when I think about again
like Assassin's Creed I think know to me
that's a game that wraps itself up it is
a story which is sort of contained right
so so anything you add on to that is
just sort of like a different experience
at that point six superfluous or it's
been take it out mmm which which is like
the worst possible thing what do you
think my yeah I don't know it seems like
it
very much a case by case basis cuz you
have like rocket League which would make
sense to keep adding incrementally to it
because no it's like these small you
know aesthetic things that you can pay
two bucks for every once in a while it's
like I've bought every single one of
those yeah I don't buy this stuff
usually yeah but if you had paid but if
they had set up front do you want to do
a 30-dollar season pass for the next
three years it the season pass
inherently becomes a gamble especially
when the developers like you had
mentioned they themselves don't know
sometimes um you know a lot of
developers now I mean not that this is
the case with a for access but I
remember Jake Salomon saying that they
did not start working on the DLC until
XCOM 2 was finished right so in that's
another case where they don't know
what's going to be coming out and I
don't believe there was a season pass
for that but I mean obviously there's
paid DLC down the road I think it's just
I think it's worth waiting to see what
you're getting into because you know
like if you pay for the season pass
you're locked in and uh I don't know it
does always raise suspicions with me I
don't know that all developers are
inherently doing it to just kind of get
money up front but i guess that like
inherently that's what's for so I don't
know I've always been kind of suspicious
about it yeah I can return a game I
don't like or at least trade it back in
for credit what I do the season pass
that's full of stuff that I just don't
care about yeah especially in the
digital domain it's way harder to make
those cult-like those calls right up
front I was asking just in the better
cuz i really love to know like how they
sell like we've no visibility on how
these season passes do you have to
imagine it some of them do pretty well
like i imagine call of duties for
instance like they built a leech off of
that obviously that's not around anymore
but and i was trying to look a lot like
you know steam spire something to see if
you could like figure out what the sales
were of them but there's none there you
can't see it i just i'd love to know cuz
to me it's like who's buying these like
even when i worked in retail people
didn't really pre-order that often like
we put all this effort into making sure
there's pre order stuff all over the
shops but like people didn't really
pre-order yeah that they kind of knew
they pre order for the ones we're like
oh you're gonna have a problem getting
GTA 4 because there's just gonna it's
gonna be sold out but like other ones
these days does that even happen do you
sell out I mean like digital now anyway
so right right exactly so you have that
option mmm but yeah like special
editions are the only things worth
pre-ordering a think yeah it's really
weird I feel like like for instance fire
emblem was like that's a really good
case for a pre-order like game because
there
making a couple of yeah it's all in 15
minutes edition I'd love to know the
wood to see the word thing is is then
when we like talk to people you know in
the comments are on the chatter whatever
it's almost unanimously people who do
not like DLC season biases so like is
this oh yeah just wondering like is this
trend against it or reaction to that
reality or if we are only viewing this
very small piece of the pie and got
actually there are millions of people
pre-ordering in buying season pass
that's a problem we face being in the
games press anyway we have such act like
this weird hyper focus on like our
little world we try to understand the
broader view but it's difficult and I
think publishers probably have that same
problem understanding their audience
completely yeah that I guess extrapolate
a little bit I guess it would I hope it
does become a trying to help that
developers and publishers have realized
there's enough of a stigma attached to
the deals like this then maybe it's
actually becomes harmful to have mice in
the long run like that's what I was
wondering is like the same thing in any
business is if you're going after money
it usually takes a couple years before
people realize that this is a bad idea
usually take somebody losing their job
and a new person coming and going let's
not do this [ __ ] anymore to stop for
them to stop doing it so I wonder if
this is a lot of yeah companies being
like finally like actually this is
causing more harm than good it's ruining
the relationship with our community
that's you know an investment that's
really important maybe we should stop
doing it I mean Ubisoft definitely have
to have that reaction with you know
pulling back an assassin's creed a
little bit and like not being so crazy
about their DLC plans in future so like
when I yay oh sorry like when I see
something about a season pass I
immediately see a publisher who's
desperate mmm which may or may not be
true but that's sort of my my immediate
takeaway is like oh they're not going to
make enough on the game that they've
released and they need to sort of like
you know stuff the coffers with ya put
this money that they'll put forward to
put into something down the road but
right now it's like crap we got to be
some more money back um I'm rig grin
Jean pan I'm gonna go with I think
publishers don't care have any pre order
or by DLC for them the numbers don't
matter because it's fun actually
benefits the many out like that's a good
point it's like any money are in this
money you know especially if it's
additional content on top of your your
base game like I wonder how hard it is
for them to like extrapolate how much it
costs to make the DLC considering so
much of the work for the deal
he was already done again it's probably
case by case but or even like subsequent
games whether the sequels or other
properties you know talking to a ton of
developers they always say if you're a
bigger company I remember when I used to
talk to like Looking Glass Studios I
said every game they made was just the
most like 70-something percent of the
money was going towards something else
they were going to make or making it's
just this I don't know if that's still a
case cuz this was a few years ago but
like a cascading structure that kind of
just keeps feeding back into itself yeah
trickle-down effect yeah hmm there you
go ah all right let us know what you
think let us know with your anecdotal
evidence do you buy season passes did
you buy season passes in the past and
then stop buying them now maybe I wonder
if that's a trend the people have had
yeah the fallout dlc for instance is
that one that you've jumped in on let us
know in the comments below